bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin vous avez été très actif
pendant cette crise sanitaire mettant en
avant quelques contradictions dans la
gestion par le gouvernement
la france n'avait t elle vraiment aucune
autre solution que d'attendre la
livraison de masques commandés à
l'étranger aucune entreprise mais avait
les capacités à fournir le pays plus
rapidement mais le problème c'est que
nous sommes gouvernés par des imbéciles
qui effectivement n'ont aucune prévision
c'est-à-dire que nous avons gouverner
c'est prévoir n'est pas gouvernée on est
administré dans ce pays
nous avons des décisions qui sont prises
à la petite semaine jour après jour mais
nous n'avons aucune vision globale des
choses
cette crise en est le témoin manifeste
nous sommes gouvernés par des
irresponsables qui concrètement
effectivement n'ont aucun sens de l'état
c'est tout et cette pandémie l'a montré
cette histoire des masques et de pénurie
en est l'archétype
si vous voulez personnes alors qu'on a
des alertes sanitaires effectivement qui
émane de l'étranger eh bien on a des
sleepings contracte un vous savez ces
contrats que l'on peut activer on n'a
plus de stocks non avec ou pas qu'on
peut activer diable quand on commence à
avoir des éléments qui tendent à établir
que ça va chauffer commandes ont laissé
masque a qui vont laisser contrat mais
non on a choisi de ne rien faire
on a aussi en tête les propos d'agnès 12
ans ex ministre de la santé devenue
candidate à la mairie de paris déclarant
avoir vu la première ce qui se passait
en chine dès le mois de décembre alors
on peut s'interroger pourquoi est-ce que
rien n'a été entrepris plus tôt par le
gouvernement pour parer au mieux à la
situation qui allait s'avérer très
compliqué et bien alors je vais vous
répondre d'abord un c'est précisément ce
que la cour de justice de la république
aura à trancher
et lorsqu'on ose venir me dire que
déposer une plainte relève du populisme
pénal comme le diable finkielkraut je
pense que monsieur finkielkraut et moi
ne vivons pas dans le même monde et que
monsieur finkielkraut et mes clients ne
vivent pas dans le même sens à ses
premiers points mais deuxième point on a
tous la réponse
2 pourquoi rien n'a été fait madame
busin va plus loin elle vous dit j'ai
averti le premier ministre
j'ai averti le gouvernement alors
aujourd'hui yann lorence un peu ses
propos dans le figaro mais le fait est
que si elle ne nie pas mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'effectivement
il fallait regarder du côté des
municipales nous avons été obsédé par
les municipales nous avons été obsédé
par une politique politicienne et qui
donc a fait fi du principe de précaution
c'est tout au plus fort de la crise il
ya aussi il y a eu aussi cette
interdiction a donné aux pharmaciens de
vendre des masques elles ont été
réquisitionnés pour le personnel
soignant comment est ce que vous voyez
ce point très précisément alors certes
les pharmaciens eu interdiction de vente
mais attention jusqu'au 23 mars à partir
du 23 mars
il pouvait en faire venir sans problème
et les vendre dans un limite d'âge
atteint stock effectivement trimestriels
sauf que l'ordre national des
pharmaciens que nous poursuivons par
ailleurs a fait croire aux pharmaciens
qui tous les masques étaient
réquisitionnés sans aucune distinction
et que les vendre les exposerait à des
sanctions pénales
ce qui était faux donc nous avons
organisé volontairement la pénurie
nous avons pour des raisons que la
justice aura à trancher volontairement
privé les français de masques à un
moment où effectivement il en avait
besoin
c'est totalement hallucinant j'ajoute un
point c'est que la vérité dans ce pays
est relativement simple c'est que
finalement comme nous sommes capables de
rien anticipé absolument rien eh bien
nous nous trouvons dans une situation
absolument chaotique
ni plus ni moins une pénurie volontaire
vous dites est ce que tu as causé par un
peu facile finalement au cir au sortir
de la crise de porter de telles
critiques parce que personne ne pensait
pouvoir être confronté à ce genre de
situation sanitaire
alors d'abord je n'ai pas attendu la fin
de la crise pour émettre des critiques
je les ai émis dès le début de la crise
et mieux que ça j'ai été le premier à
les émettre
j'ai été le premier un des premiers
jouets et plateaux télé sur au nom des
soignants que je défends à dire
attention moi j'exerce en italie il ya
un problème ça va plan sa vache
ça va flamber ça va flamber ça va
flamber sauf que personne n'a entendu
personne n'a écouté la vérité
effectivement c'est que oui nous sommes
sur une infraction volontaires pour des
raisons qui sont liées à la politique
mais nous sommes sur une infraction
volontaire et regardez je vois vos
images en même temps c'est très
intéressant on par les entreprises
françaises
mais les entreprises françaises se sont
fait littéralement roulé dans la farine
comme les pharmaciens puisque pendant ce
temps là pendant qu on pleurait pour
qu'elles participent à l'effort national
ont la grande distribution elle était
autorisée a commandés massivement bien
en chine ne serait ce que ça a un petit
mois aussi assez rapidement parce que le
temps lui manque mais à l'étranger
comment est-ce que cette question des
masques a été gérée basset pays
dépendants mais en fait les pays
étrangers si vous voulez si on prend
exception faite de la corée du sud
moi je vois en italie les deux phases la
première phase où ça a été très mal
gérée mais parce que ils ont vraiment
pris la crise en pleine figure avec une
violence extraordinaire elle n'avait pas
le recul qu'on a on avait nous pour nous
préparer et ensuite j'ai vu une deuxième
phase dans laquelle cette question des
masques elle a été réglée dès mi mars
dès que la chine a réouvert c'est à dire
effectivement fin février début mars
on a on a plus vraiment de problème
d'approvisionnement de basque et un
petit temps pour remise en route mais
dès mi mars on a plus de problème c'est
à dire que moment où nous ça a flambé
l'italie déjà passé à autre chose au
sujet des masques et avait des stocks
qui commençait à revenir et qui ont été
suffisants merci d'avoir pris le temps
de répondre à nos questions ce matin
fabrice di vizio je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat vous représentez des
professionnels de santé